here joining me now Molly Hemingway Fox
News contributor editor-in-chief of the
Federalist Ben demenich editor at large
for The Spectator Fox News contributor
as well Molly
um your reaction to this Newsome Grizzly
uh bill that they just passed I think of
the abortions that take place in
California I I don't even want to think
about uh you know what this would mean
but what's going on here it does just
seem like The Logical endpoint of some
of the radical policies coming out of
California which has a strong focus on
their their beliefs on climate change
where they view humans are something of
a Scourge or a virus and so it just
seems logical that they would include in
this that that human remains can be used
for composting these problems with
fertilizer though which are also related
to this bill are denying Humanity
throughout the world we need fertilizer
to grow crops for Farmers to have
sustainable Farms that can keep going
and so it's just a it's a massive
problem globally
then I just learned that we should
actually I guess be celebrating tonight
because Nancy Pelosi just made a huge
announcement watch this
we saved the planet we're saving the
planet with record 360 billion dollars
to save the planet and generating jobs
and cleaner air and cleaner water and
jobs and security
she does that weird gesticulation that
doesn't match the words Ben but I guess
no one has to buy an EV anymore the
planet has already been saved what's
going on here mission accomplished uh I
mean look I think that this California
bill goes a little too far in taking
ashes to ashes and dust to dust
literally as a matter of government
policy I I have to assume that it was
supported by the union of California
serial killers for climate change
prevention or something along those
lines but look we we do see I think uh
right right in front of our eyes
something amazing happening which is
that the left is being more honest than
ever about the radical nature of their
views on abortion policy and the media
complex is rushing to defend them to
spin on their behalf and you know
frankly big Tech is going along with
this you had you know Twitter slapping a
fact check confirmation from NBC on to
Stacy Abrams statement and for any of us
who is a parent has gone into a hospital
room and we all know that we've heard
you know that expression from from the
nurse saying would you like to hear your
fetus's cardiac event uh that this is
not something that anyone has ever heard
and it's because we all know this is a
baby and this is a heartbeat but the
left has to deny that in order to
further their inhumane policies yeah
just they're so radical it's it becomes
a caricature of itself Molly and I want
to switch gears here because over at CNN
today Jake Tapper spoke to French
president Emmanuel macron now listen to
the disdain that they both have for one
particular growing political movement
this trend of um nationalism populism
and racism that we're seeing all over
the world gaining power how worried are
you about this we have the crisis of
democracies of what I would call liberal
democracies open societies you know open
and very Cooperative democracies
put pressure on your people
it could destabilize them
it could destabilize
um Mali democracy is working just fine
he thinks there's a crisis because the
elites are losing notice how he
conflates uh racism and populism Tapper
too in the question right I mean because
I guess everybody in Sweden now is a
racist is that what he's saying so what
Tapper is doing is recognizing that
conservative populism which is very is
helping out the Republican Party quite a
bit making it very powerful a political
movement is multi-racial working class
it has ideas that are very popular and
able to deal with some of the major
problems that are going on in the
country right now and Jake Tapper
doesn't like that because he is a
liberal Democrat and so he tries to Tar
it as being threatening and racist but
all this is is an attempt by people in
power in our regime to keep that
conservative populism which is probably
going to do pretty well here in a couple
months from uh from from being powerful
and it shows yeah macron is scared right
Ben I mean he's he's worried because he
sees what's happening in Italy Sweden
um the UK is now going to be fracking
people want Solutions and they Elites
want to keep their power
I thought that we were supposed to get a
new CNN Laura going to a French
president to criticize America is that's
classic CNN of course
touche touche all right Molly Ben great
to see you both hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else